pseudoscience get at me hey everyone i'm
abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
in part one of this two-part series
we'll be breaking down the real reasons
why you're bloated but first let me tell
you about my sponsor better help so as
you guys know i've struggled with
anxiety my whole life and getting my
mental health under control has actually
been a really key step in healing my gut
and digestion since the brain and the
gut are so intimately connected but in
2022 i am really committing to my mental
health and working with a registered
therapist is key to supporting my goals
so i recently discovered better help
which is the world's largest online
therapist network with over 20 000
licensed professional therapists it's
not a crisis line or a self-help line
it's professional therapy done securely
anywhere anytime online now the way it
works is that you just log into your
account anytime to send a message to
your therapist and you can get a timely
response without needing to wait weeks
between appointments i know how
important this is because obviously we
can't just plan out when we have our
panic attacks or rational anxious
episodes so i thought i would dress up
for today's panic attack
you know do something a little special
make a day of it anyway
so that they land the week of our
scheduled appointment now it's also a
lot more affordable than traditional
in-person therapy and there's also
financial aid available for those in
need so if you're struggling with your
mental health definitely check out
betterhelp.com
abby's kitchen to get 10 off of your
first month of therapy again that's
betterhelp h-e-l-p
and you can join over one million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional okay let's get back to
bloating and you can pause the screen or
look at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
of course if you are new here do not
forget to subscribe to this channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on an episode and also follow
me over on tik tok and instagram at
abi's kitchen i also want to say very
clearly that all digestive issues
including bloating are remarkably
complex it was really hard for me to
make this video because the cause of
people's bloating and therefore the
appropriate treatment will be highly
individualized so for example the
recommendations for folks with bloating
from constipation would possibly make
bloating from something like sibo far
worse and vice versa so always speak to
a registered dietitian who specializes
in digestive health about your unique
case in fact i consulted with not one
but four of my gi rd colleagues in this
video to get their clinical insight so a
big thank you to dasha aguilnek amber
gourley caitlyn self and lacy dunn for
all of their help as always i'm going to
be leaving links to their practices
below next i want to quickly flag that
you know diet culture has kind of
co-opted the term bloating to be like a
more pc term for fat it is also
pathologized the very normal experience
of your stomach expanding and
contracting throughout the day this is
wellness culture bs
i'm sorry i'm allergic to bull it is
normal to experience daily gas and it's
normal for your bowel habits to change
in response to certain foods or times of
the month but if you're experiencing
bloating that is very painful linked to
other side effects like nausea where
you're visibly distended to the point
that you maybe look pregnant or it feels
like there's a balloon in there and that
these symptoms seem to be chronic and
persistent every day that's when it's
definitely worth reaching out for help
so in part one we're going to be
discussing the top reasons why you may
be experiencing bloating and then in
part two we're going to be getting into
what to do about it reason number one
food intolerances undiagnosed food
intolerances to things like dairy gluten
or literally any other food that's being
poorly digested and therefore fermenting
in the gut can of course cause excess
gas production and therefore bloating
allergies can also occasionally cause
bloating because the histamine response
can increase mast cell production which
may elevate estrogen which can cause
constipation and that can ultimately
result in bloating but generally
speaking bloating is more of an
intolerance than an allergy symptom
unfortunately while food allergies can
be reliably diagnosed intolerances are a
little more hit and miss those food
sensitivity tests that you see all over
instagram are not evidenced based so an
elimination diet which should be
supervised by a registered dietitian is
really the gold standard of care here
reason number two sensitivity to high
fodmap foods so fodmaps are short chain
carbohydrates that are poorly absorbed
in the small intestine leaving them to
be fermented by bacteria which then
causes gas some of the more common
offenders include foods like cruciferous
veggies beans and legumes dairy wheat as
well as some non-caloric sweeteners
however it's important to note that
sensitivity to high fodmap foods is
highly individualized meaning that you
could be sensitive to certain high
fodmap foods in specific quantities but
able to tolerate others in higher
quantities again this is why it's so
important to be working with a dietitian
to help you eat the greatest variety of
foods with the fewest amount of symptoms
reason number three you're swallowing
too much air what we consume and how we
consume it can increase the amount of
air that we swallow which can build up
in the digestive tract and lead to
uncomfortable gas so things like
drinking carbonated beverages drinking
through a straw chewing a lot of gum
eating while talking or eating in a
hurry can all contribute to the amount
of air entering our bodies and therefore
bloating now reason number four you are
under eating or suffering from an eating
disorder now this is a big topic but
there is a strong correlation between
disordered eating and bloating for a
variety of reasons in short chronically
under eating can reduce stomach acid
production and serotonin levels which
slows motility and it can cause a
sluggish thyroid and it can also cause
gastroparesis which also slows digestion
this often can perpetuate further
disordered eating because people
wrongfully assume that they have food
intolerances because they have symptoms
when they do eat them so they become
more fearful of eating and then eat even
less and this actually just makes the
digestive symptoms worse now this
deserves a whole video in itself so if
that's something of interest definitely
leave me a comment below reason number
five you're not getting enough fiber and
hydration can i get you anything
water would be nice one of the major
causes of bloating is actually
constipation or poor motility if you're
not consuming enough fiber and water to
help your stool move through the bowels
you're gonna get backed up which means
more fermentation and more gas bloating
and distension so you'll want to aim for
at least 25 to 38 grams of fiber per day
depending on sex size and tolerance and
a mix of soluble and insoluble fiber
from foods like fruit veggies whole
grains and other plants and don't forget
that with any fiber you need enough
water to help propel that bulk through
the bowel so making sure that you're
staying hydrated is really important to
preventing yourself getting more backed
up and speaking of backed up reason
number six is you're eating too much
fiber so fiber is a really delicate
balance when it comes to digestion it's
a real goldilocks in the three bears
situation so like the porridge can
easily be too hot or too cold i hate it
when someone messes with my porridge
it's sometimes hard to get it just right
but consuming excess of fiber is usually
accompanied by a heavy load of fodmaps
which can cause fermentation which leads
to gas this is especially an issue if
you're not used to consuming fiber and
you suddenly consume a huge load of it
and perhaps we're just not consuming
enough water to help support it this is
why it's worth working with a
professional for any constipation
related issues because there really can
be some careful trial and error to
ensure that you're getting enough fiber
but not too much to help move the bowels
without excess bulk and that brings me
to reason number seven inadequate
digestive outputs anytime we see someone
make any drastic quick changes to their
diet whether it's you know a crash
weight loss diet or an unsupervised
elimination diet eating disorder etc
there's a risk of normal digestion going
so
[Music]
major fast changes to diet don't allow
your body the time it needs to really
catch up on digestive outputs
like creating the right enzymes or
stomach acid amounts so for example if
you've been dairy free for years and you
suddenly have a big bowl of ice cream
your body has gotten used to not having
to produce the lactase enzyme to break
that down so
yeah it's probably gonna hurt ditto for
folks who've gone vegan and who suddenly
have a 16 ounce steak their body didn't
get the urgent memo in time to produce
enough of the protease enzymes and
stomach acid needed to break that porta
house down so we need to really go slow
to train the gut to upregulate the
enzyme and stomach acid production to
meet the body's changing demands moving
on to reason number eight hormones now
the rise in progesterone hormone leading
up to that time of the month can not
only contribute to the feeling of
bloating from some water retention but
also typically results in constipation
which can further exacerbate symptoms of
gas bloating and abdominal discomfort i
know i'm simplifying this because
hormones is another one of those
massively complicated topics so let's
just leave it at that and if you want
more hormone related content let me know
in the comments below but speaking of a
massive topic reason number nine is that
you have a functional gi disorder so if
you've ruled out all of the above and
you're still experiencing bloating it
could be a sign that there may be a more
serious gastrointestinal disorder going
on some common digestive disorders that
can cause bloating include things like
irritable bowel syndrome ibs
inflammatory bowel disease ibd celiac
disease hypochloridia histamine
intolerance and pancreatic insufficiency
now i'm not going to get into the nitty
gritty on each of these but if you do
suspect there is a medical issue be
proactive and be pushy with your primary
health care provider to get the
appropriate tests run now moving on to
reason number 10 infection overgrowth or
dysbiosis now there are a number of
potential infections and overgrowths
that can potentially contribute to
digestive symptoms like bloating so
things like h pylori sibo c fo
c diff candida worms parasites or just
general dysbiosis in the gut the
diagnostic tools that we have for these
include things like breath tests like
you saw me do in my sibo series or gi
mapping or other stool samples that your
doctor can order from a lab in any case
do not follow some tick talkers protocol
and assume that you have like an
infection or an overgrowth without the
proper tests run because there are
pharmaceutical and herbal treatments for
these that are very specific to the
cause now reason number 11 is thyroid
dysfunction so the thyroid is so
important not only is it your metabolic
epicenter but it's also in charge of
communicating with every other system to
produce enough bile acid pancreatic acid
enzymes and to stimulate motility
you name it so folks with hypothyroidism
or hashimoto's often experience severe
digestive distress and bloating because
the thyroid receptors in the abdomen are
not getting enough thyroid hormone so
the gut isn't getting those digestive
signals as a result we see poor motility
which leads to constipation which means
the food has more time to ferment and
therefore a lot more gas and bloating
which also predisposes these folks to
other conditions like sibo and candida
in any case these symptoms usually
improve dramatically once we correct the
thyroid hormone reason number 12 trauma
to the brain gut axis now i've briefly
spoken about the brain gut axis before
but in short this is the bi-directional
communication between the central and
enteric nervous system that links
cognitive centers of the brain with
intestinal functioning it's a concept
behind the idea of having butterflies in
your stomach when you're nervous any
physical or emotional trauma that
damages this brain gut axis has the
power to cause bloating so this could be
actual physical trauma like a football
player's head injury or more
psychological trauma related to ptsd
depression or anxiety which is also
often related to low serotonin levels
now what about excess sodium and sugar
so we often use the term bloated to
describe a feeling when we eat like a
really salty meal or have a huge sugar
load but this puffy feeling
is more accurately described as water
retention in the case of salt high
sodium foods can cause our bodies to
retain excess water which can also
contribute to feeling puffy or in
colloquial terms bloated with
carbohydrates when consumed in excess
the energy that we don't immediately
need gets stored as glycogen along with
three grams of water for every gram of
carbohydrates stored so this explains
why people who go on really low carb
diets drop a ton of weight really
quickly it's a lot of water storage
weight from the glycogen depleting now
to close off i want to remind everyone
that this is not an exhaustive list of
causes and everyone's bloating
experience is going to be unique and
often multi-factorial but i do hope that
this gives you all a little bit of
insight into your own digestive patterns
and whether or not it's time to bring
your case to a skilled practitioner for
advice so on that note that is all that
i have for you guys today if you liked
it be sure to give it the thumbs up stay
tuned for part two in this bloating
episode don't forget to subscribe to
this channel and i will see you next
time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]